[Música]
hola cómo están buenas tardes
yo muy feliz de poder tener este público
maravilloso que nos están acompañando en
estas charlas de cerebro porque me
siento feliz de poder ser la primera
speaker que va a darles una breve
historia vamos a hacer de cuenta que
todos nosotros estamos presenciando una
discusión de herramientas en un taller
de carpintería y las herramientas se
están discutiendo unas contra otras
respetándose todas sus debilidades y de
entrada se la tenían tomada con el
martillo y le dice hemos decidido en
este equipo que tu martillo ya no vas
más el martillo se pregunta por qué
porque todo el tiempo te la pasas
golpeando y golpeando y no haces otra
cosa más que voltear todo el tiempo
metes bulla
ya ya no estás cansado es por eso que
hemos decidido parte del equipo bueno
perfecto y ser martillo pero yo no me
voy solo conmigo se viene el
destornillador
y el destornillador dice pero yo porque
porque todo el tiempo te la pasas dando
vueltas y vueltas a lo mismo y no sabes
hacer otra cosa más que dar vueltas
bueno perfecto si eso han decidido en el
equipo yo también me voy
pero conmigo se viene la llave y la
llave también se auto pregunta iris de
pero yo por qué porque si no es una
tuerca del 8 o no es una tuerca de 10 no
sirve todavía pues es una llave inglesa
que te adaptará pero no te hará bueno
entonces y eso también les molesta
perfecto yo también me voy del equipo
pero conmigo se viene la lima la lima
que anda linda que no es áspera
cualquiera se acerca a ella todo el día
se la pasa limando y limando y no hace
otra cosa más y más
bueno dice también la lima entonces se
han fijado en mis defectos también me
voy del equipo pero no me voy sola me
voy con el metro y el metro dice pero yo
por qué porque eres milimétrico todo el
día te la pasas midiendo milímetro tras
milímetro centímetro tras centímetro y
si no es la medida exacta vuelves a
medir y vuelves a medir qué pesadito
eres metro bueno perfecto dice el metro
pero conmigo se viene la garlopa
bien podía estar en un grupo que se
llame garlopa pero nada fuese tu nombre
es que no profundiza todo el tiempo
estás en la superficie y así las
herramientas unas contra otras estaban
resultando sus debilidades hasta que
ingresa el carpintero y empieza a
una herramienta otra herramienta empieza
a realizar su trabajo en pin pan pim pam
empieza a realizar al cabo de pocas
horas una hermosa mesa como ésta
acaba su trabajo el carpintero y se va
y en la sala de reunión hay un minuto de
silencio y la amiga sierra toma la mano
y dice compañeros toda la mañana nos
hemos pasado discutiendo y respetándonos
nuestras debilidades cuando ha venido el
carpintero y ha trabajado con nosotros
con nuestras mejores cualidades y
virtudes y ha podido sacar esta hermosa
mesa donde van a poder comer muchas
familias donde se van a poder reunir
muchas personas y en la que se van a
poder hacer muchas cosas productivas
para la sociedad
y desde ese momento las herramientas
tomaron conciencia de que cuando
trabajaban desde sus mejores cualidades
suscriptores podían hacer grandes cosas
así que amigas y amigos primera
herramienta siempre trabajemos desde
nuestras cualidades y nuestras virtudes
y el trabajo en equipo porque cuando se
trabaja en equipos de nuestras mejores
cualidades se logra grandes cosas
he aquí el ejemplo de los muchachos de
terex que han podido realizar este
hermoso y magno evento donde se va a
poder difundir muchas charlas
importantes para la sociedad así que a
no olvidar primera herramienta trabajar
desde nuestras virtudes nuestras
cualidades para poder hacer grandes
proyectos antes
pero vamos sigamos como segunda
herramienta les tengo
unos 20
en la sociedad
se divisa dos tipos de personas
y se utiliza por ende dos tipos de
lentes los lentes que no nos sirven y
los lentes que sí nos sirven vamos a
empezar por los lentes que no nos sirven
yo los llamo los lentes de josé luís más
conocidos como los lentes de pepe a
ustedes se preguntarán quienes petén pp
era un amigo al que yo recogían todas
las mañanas para ir a trabajo en el
coche
y pp era una persona amargada y
pesimista y en el momento que se subía a
mi coche me decía
priscila
de día está lloviendo hay un
trancón y de paso vamos a llegar tarde
al trabajo
yo le decía pero pepe está negativo si a
nubloso el cielo hay trancón pero vamos
a llegar en hora y para mi mala suerte
pp tenía razón llegábamos tarde el día
era totalmente negro y todos los
objetivos del día que uno se había
planeado no los llegábamos a cumplir
y al día siguiente volvía a pasar lo
mismo pepe se subía a mi auto y me decía
vigila si ayer era un día o rendo hoy
día va a ser un día catastrófico
y para mi mala suerte volvía a tener
razón pepe era un día totalmente obscuro
aquellos días que nos levantamos con el
pie izquierdo y todo nos sale mal
entonces
un día decidí
pepe ya no vas más conmigo
por qué me estás marcando el día me
estás amargando la vida yo no puedo
seguir más contigo
te dejo un lado nuestra amistad dejemos
volar
ahora ustedes se preguntarán pp es un
personaje real
pepe se nos introduce en la cabeza lo
que los psicólogos llaman pensamiento
negativo
pensamiento negativo pesimista
entonces se dan cuenta muchas veces
nosotros los autos saboteamos nos
enfocamos en nuestras cosas en nuestras
debilidades nos enfocamos en tener un
mal día y el universo nos escucha
entonces estas gafas no sirven de la
sociedad pero si se dan cuenta no sólo
nosotros los autos saboteamos y personas
que lo hacen
se ocupan de introducir que a pep en la
cabeza y te dicen tú no vas a lograr no
vas a poder en el proyecto que estás
invirtiendo te va a ir mal
y muchas veces nos auto limitamos a
poder hacer muchas cosas
entonces las gafas de pepe no nos sirve
pero hay otras que sí que sí son útiles
para la sociedad
como me quieras
efe
créanme lo de aquí la vida se ve de
diferente color de aquí se ve la vida de
diferente manera por qué porque son las
gafas del positivismo del optimismo y
las gafas de la empatía y cuando hablo
del optimismo me refiero a ese optimismo
esperanzador a ese optimismo inteligente
que uno dice vamos las cosas me va a ir
bien va a marchar bien y porque las
gafas de la empatía
porque todos nosotros debemos ser
empáticos santander ante la sociedad es
tener empatía es ponerse en los zapatos
de la otra persona
miren en la vida realmente se pierde
muchas cosas perdemos amigos perdemos
familiares queridos perdemos dinero
perdemos negocios proyectos podemos
perderlo todo pero hay una cosa que no
debemos perder es la humanidad cuando un
ser humano pierde la humanidad y lo
pierde todo porque es la riqueza más
valiosa del ser humano
entonces cuando un amigo cuando un
compañero de trabajo su familia necesita
que le des una mano de zela porque ahí
estás practicando la comunicación estás
practicando la escucha activa que es
tener escucha activa es apagar los
pensamientos atender comprender lo que
tú
entonces estas gafas si son útiles para
nosotros es una herramienta importante
para el transcurso de nuestras vidas
ser positivistas ser empáticos y con eso
se logra grandes
pero vamos sigamos avanzando
todos conocen esto
es un nivel y para qué sirve un nivel
para ver si las cosas están rectas no es
cierto por ejemplo esta mesa está
fabricada recta también el piso los
propios
entonces nosotros como seres humanos
tenemos la herramienta interna que es
nivelar nuestras emociones el ser humano
es un nivelador emocional ya qué me
refiero con esto ojo que no estoy
hablando solo de emociones positivas o
negativas el ser humano ya viene con las
yo no puedo decidir solo tener emociones
positivas no también tengo tristezas
amarguras penurias porque porque la vida
me pone así adversidades
como les digo el ser humano tiene la
capacidad de poder gestionar sus
emociones
entonces nosotros somos como un
nivelador emocional
y la verdad créanme el ser humano es
creado tan perfectamente que tiene
indicadores cuando tu corazón cuando tu
alma tiene gozo es porque estás yendo
por el camino correcto
pero si estás haciendo algo que no te
gusta algo con el que estás totalmente
disconforme es nuestra mente está se
equivoca
entonces para eso sirve nuestro nivel
emocional y les voy a poner un ejemplo
viene mi jefe y me dice presidente tú ya
no trabajas en esta empresa
le damos tu carta de agradecimiento
muchas gracias por los años de
prestación cómo me siento
puedo ser puedo tener dos caminos no
sentirme muy feliz porque ya voy a dejar
de trabajar y puedo ocuparme de mi
familia o sentirme triste triste abatida
porque ya no voy a tener una fuente
laboral
voy a estar desempleada y tengo que
alimentar niños y educación de mis niños
etcétera pero qué hago en mi está el
poder de decidir de poder nivelar y de
poder vivir encarte bien qué significa
poder vivir en carpe diem aprovechar el
momento entonces bien bueno como me ya
no voy a trabajar en la empresa me darán
mis beneficios sociales y va a ser una
oportunidad para que yo pueda pasar una
vacación con mi familia tantos años me
la he pasado trabajando y me olvidé de
pasar unos momentos hermosos con mi
familia creo que su oportunidad de hacer
voy a hacer un viaje
y entonces se dan cuenta estoy nivelando
entonces es una herramienta muy
importante que interna que el ser humano
tiene el de poder nivelar las emociones
y de poder tener una vida armoniosa y
sin frustrar
pero bueno sigamos con más herramientas
hasta les he traído mi jugo
fabricado de gomaespuma
y quiero que sepan que el ser humano
también tiene en la cabeza una
gomaespuma que es nuestro cerebro
y a qué me refiero con este material de
gomaespuma esto ha sido fabricado
prácticamente para los niños para que no
se maltrate no se hagan daño los niños
de 0 a 1 año
y es fabricado de un material que no se
rompe
es un material flexible
es por eso que se dice que esto es
fabricado de un material resiliente y un
material resiliente en física tiene
asociación con algo flexible
y cuando se aprisiona vuelve a su estado
normal
entonces déjenme decirles que el ser
humano tiene un cerebro resilientes
porque no podemos levantarnos ante las
adversidades de la vida
si evidentemente el cerebro muchas veces
capta
cuando te ocurre algo malo pero lo va
procesando y poco a poco vas volviendo a
tu vida va retomando tu plan de vida
y nuevamente estamos luchando con todo
lo que hacemos
es por eso que se dice la resiliencia es
hacer frente a las adversidades de la
vida
y transformar ese dolor en fuerza motora
para que salgas más invicto de las
adversidades
si se dan cuenta
la vida está llena de problemas quién no
tiene problemas de un familiar enfermo
quien no tiene problemas de
endeudamiento
y no tiene problemas todo mundo
atraviesa por diversos problemas hasta
los empresarios más grandes y
multimillonarios tienen problemas los
actores de cine tienen problemas y ahí
el ejemplo de robbie williams
lo tenía todo tenía casos dinero casa
pero tenía problemas internos él me con
psicólogos entendidos en la materia
podía subsanar los problemas internos
que tengo tanto así que lo ha llevado al
suicidio
entonces muchas veces nosotros los seres
humanos desconocemos este tipo de
herramientas
pero espero que de esta charla ustedes
se lleven algo bonito y productivo que
vean que no la vida tiene altibajos pero
depende de nosotros como vamos a saber
vivirla
y espero que lo tomen en cuenta que
siempre siempre tenemos que trabajar
desde nuestras virtudes nuestras
cualidades tener esas gafas empática de
ver siempre la vida con positivismo de
ser
siempre tener una sonrisa en la cara
de tener ese nivelador emocional que
cuando se atraviese una llama la
oportunidad de decir bueno
veré que soluciones y alternativas tengo
para seguir adelante con mi vida
y sobre todo tener un cerebro resiliente
de hacer frente a todas las adversidades
de poder vivir en cárter y en aprovechar
el momento de cada instante que se me
atraviese cosas buenas cosas malas esta
es la vida lamentablemente el ser humano
vive de oportunidades y vive también de
fracasos
pero de eso se aprende
y es por eso que quiero terminar con
esta frase de carlos risso
literalmente todos estamos rotos por
dentro
hasta las traigo la más rota
gracias
[Música]